j'ai des plans pour tout le monde j'ai
un plan pour quelqu'un je sais pas qui
c'est un tout ce que je sais c'est que
je vais baiser sa vie et contre le plan
admettons qui s'appelle bruno écoute le
plan pour bruno je vais me faire tatouer
sur le corps tous les visages de la
famille de bruno pousse la mère de bruno
le père de bruno la grand-mère de bruno
allongé regard perçant je vais attendre
que toute la famille se réunit ce genre
à l'anniversaire de bruno je vais
rentrer par effraction dans la maison je
vais mettre tout nu et je vais les
regarder
et un moment donné ils vont se
reconnaître
tatoué sûrement avec aucune idée de qui
je suis ils vont être là mais mamie je
pense que c'est toi sous les tétons cet
inconnu là je vais mettre à pleurer et
je lui dire maintenant bruno explique
leur et je vais m'en aller
[Applaudissements]